Ich wollte nie
einen Schweizer heiraten.
Ich weiss nicht wieso,
aber schon seit meiner Kindheit.
Vom ersten Augenblick an
war Martin sehr, sehr ...
... sehr hübsch in meinen Augen.
Sie sagte mir: "Du, nimm meine Hand
und bring mich überall dort hin,
wo du willst."
* Herzschläge *
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
Grüezi wohl.
Soll ich das als Erstes?
- Ich gebe es Ihnen gleich so.
Ich brauche auch Ihren Pass.
(Alles lässt er zurück,
aber das Fahrrad muss mit -
auch wenn Quebec
gerade im Schnee versinkt.)
(Der Meteorologe
müsste es eigentlich wissen.)
Sie werden einfach lachen, dass im
Winter jemand mit dem Fahrrad kommt.
Das macht in Kanada
extrem wenig Sinn.
(Thomas Kleiber wandert für
seinen Mann David nach Kanada aus.)
(Den Job beim "SRF Meteo"
hat er gekündigt,
die Wohnung geräumt
und sich von allen verabschiedet.)
Ich hoffe,
ich habe nicht zu grosses Heimweh.
Ich verlasse ein wunderschönes Land,
eine tolle Familie, tolle Freunde.
Ich hoffe,
ich werde kein Heimweh haben,
aber ehrlich gesagt
freue ich mich auch.
Ich freue mich auf den Flug,
ich freue mich, David zu sehen
und dass es endlich losgeht.
Es ist schwierig,
man muss ein wenig die Gefühle
für den anderen unterdrücken,
wenn man über Monate getrennt ist.
Am Anfang wird es auch
etwas speziell sein,
man fällt wieder
in den Paarmodus zurück.
Jetzt hatten wir lange
quasi den Singlemodus.
Emotional
sind diese Wechsel nicht einfach.
Korken knallen!
Ciao. Tschüss.
Mach's gut! Bis nächstes Jahr.
- Danke, bis bald.
Ciao, Thöme.
- Tschüss.
Ähm ... Christian.
Ciao, Thömi.
- Vielen Dank.
Mach's gut!
(Abschied von den Eltern,
dem Bruder - und dann auf und davon.)
(Auf Thomas wartet zwar sein Mann,
aber sonst sehr viel Ungewohntes.)
(Z.B. wohnen sie
im Haus der Schwiegereltern
in Davids ehemaligem Kinderzimmer.)
(Wie er mit diesen neuen Umständen
zurechtkommt,
weiss er selbst
noch nicht so richtig.)
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
# Take my hand.
Säntis. Here it is.
Yeah, on top of the mountain.
So, no, it was ...
Up on top of a Swiss mountain.
Die Katze war schon im Sack.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Wenn ich hier über die Bucht von
Mount Maunganui blicke, verstehe ich,
warum es Katja aus Bischofszell
hierher verschlagen hat.)
(Katja ist Ökonomin
und hat an der HSG studiert.)
(Sie arbeitet Vollzeit
bei der Bank of New Zealand
als Beraterin für Grosskunden.)
(Heute ist alles etwas anders -
kein Wunder, denn es ist der
letzte Arbeitstag vor Weihnachten.)
(Gearbeitet
wird heute nicht wirklich,
dafür wichtelt Katjas Team.)
(Bei sommerlichen Temperaturen.)
(Frau) This is nice!
- Yeah, it's nice.
Wow!
- Das ist ein gutes Geschenk.
Super.
Oft geben sie ganz doofe Geschenke,
also einfach lustige.
Fertig.
- Jetzt müssen wir noch arbeiten.
Ein bisschen Schweiz im Büro.
Oh, is it your birthday?
Happy birthday!
Thank you.
- Is it your birthday?
Oh!
Oho!
Roger.
Aber wie ist es eigentlich?
Wir haben hier
ein Stück Schweiz in Neuseeland,
aber du willst ja vielleicht zurück -
schaust du dich nach Jobs um?
Ich habe mal
meine Fühler ausgestreckt,
um zu sehen, wie schwierig
oder wie einfach es wird.
Ich glaube, es ist etwas schwierig
von so weit weg.
Aber wenn ich einen Job finde,
dann wäre auch AJ dabei.
Das ist die Voraussetzung:
Ich muss einen Job finden.
Also "müssen",
ich bin ja diejenige, die arbeitet,
und er ist der Stay-at-home-dad.
Wenn ich ihn vor
vollendete Tatsachen stellen kann,
dann ist es perfekt.
(Ich glaube, die beiden haben
noch einiges zu diskutieren.)
I'm hiding.
- Where are you?
(AJ war lange Zeit Surfprofi, jetzt
ist er im Wesentlichen Hausmann
oder Stay-at-home-dad,
wie es hier heisst.)
Katja ist
ein bisschen strenger als ich.
Narja und ich sind entspannter,
wir essen Eis
und hängen ein bisschen rum.
Nicht wahr, Narja? Wir sagen Mama
nicht, dass wir Eis essen.
Aber du verrätst uns immer!
Es ist wichtig,
für sie da zu sein,
ihr die wichtigen Sachen
beizubringen,
ihr das Gefühl
von Liebe und Sicherheit zu geben.
Ich glaube,
sie hat hier, was sie braucht.
(Etwas, das AJ selbst nicht hatte.)
(Seine Mutter verliess die Familie,
als er noch zur Schule ging.)
Do you want the unicorn?
Schlaf gut.
* Fröhliche, entspannte Musik *
Ich mache die Dinge gern schnell.
Just get it over with.
Ich mag keine Unordnung,
sondern Sauberkeit.
Katja ist anders, sie macht sogar
mehr Durcheinander als Narja.
Da braucht es jemanden,
der auf die beiden aufpasst.
(Feierabend ist Familienzeit.)
(Diese verbringen Katja, AJ und Narja
häufig am Strand.)
Narja, to the beach we go!
(Hier fühlt sich AJ am wohlsten.)
Kannst du es verantworten,
jemanden wie ihn vom Meer wegzuholen
in die Schweiz?
Ich habe ein wenig
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Es ist nicht nur ein Hobby,
sondern wirklich ein Lebensstil.
Meine Mutter sagt immer:
"Irgendwann wächst er doch da raus."
"Er kann ja in der Schweiz
snowboarden." Oder sonst etwas.
Aber das ist, als würde man
einem Bündner die Berge wegnehmen.
Der fühlt sich auch nicht wohl
oder bekommt schnell Heimweh.
Einer von euch muss immer
Kompromisse eingehen.
Einer ist immer
ein bisschen unglücklich.
Entweder bist du weit von der Schweiz
weg, oder er ist weg vom Meer.
Kompromisse muss man
in jeder Partnerschaft eingehen,
aber in so einer
internationalen Partnerschaft
sind es vielleicht noch grössere
Kompromisse, die man eingeht.
Aber letztlich
sollte man sie gerne eingehen
und man sollte es wollen,
denn es bedeutet, dass man mit der
Person zusammen ist, die man will.
Irgendwie glaube ich,
dass es einen Grund gibt,
warum ich nicht jemanden aus
dem Appenzellerland gefunden habe.
Und mit dem Thurgauer Dialekt
findet man auch nicht so viele.
Hör auf, nein!
Ich habe auch einen gefunden.
Das ist jetzt die neueste These:
Mit Thurgauer Dialekt
muss man bis nach Neuseeland,
denn dort merken sie es nicht.
Danke, Katja!
Hier hat mich noch nie jemand
wegen meines Dialektes angesprochen.
(Ja, das hat gesessen!)
(Aber hier am Strand
von Mount Maunganui
fallen einem schon noch
ein paar andere Gründe ein,
warum man das Leben in Neuseeland
und nicht zwingend
im Kanton Thurgau verbringen will.)
Yeah!
- Woohoo!
# Take my hand.
Als ich sie gesehen habe,
war sie vom Aussehen her ...
Sie ist wahnsinnig hübsch, schön
und eben auch sympathisch,
wir haben dieselben Interessen.
Sportlich.
Ja, damals waren wir noch sportlich.
Und ja, daher war mir
von Anfang an klar ...
Ich hatte zu jener Zeit,
als wir miteinander skypten,
noch andere Kontakte im Osten.
Ich hatte weitere Kontakte
in der Ukraine und in Russland.
Sobald ich mit ihr
ins Gespräch gekommen war,
mit ihr in Kontakt gekommen war,
war mir klar, dass ich
die anderen Kontakte abblocke
und dass ich das mit ihr
ernsthaft verfolge.
(Martin und Lana verliebten sich
vor sieben Jahren übers Internet
und heirateten bald darauf.)
(Seither wohnen sie in Thusis.)
(Lana stammt aus der Ukraine.)
Okay.
Das geht jetzt ...
... in den Ofen.
(Martin ist überzeugter Vegetarier.)
Lana kocht sehr gut.
Ich könnte schon selbst kochen,
aber es ist natürlich viel bequemer,
wenn man nur wenig Zeit über Mittag
hat und nicht selber kochen muss
und sich einfach hinsetzen kann.
Das ist gut.
Und die Idee war ja auch, dass ...
5 Min., okay?
... dass sie Hausfrau ist.
(V.a. seit ihr gemeinsamer Sohn Leon
auf der Welt ist.)
Ja, ich bin eher
ein Verfechter von ...
... vom traditionellen Frauenbild.
- 100 kg.
Das Frauenbild ...
Ich bin der Meinung, dass es gut
ist, wenn die Mutter zu Hause ist.
V.a. wenn man Kinder hat,
ist es gut,
wenn eine Beziehungsperson da ist.
Das finde ich gut, aber
sobald die Kinder etwas älter sind,
ist es auch in Ordnung,
wenn die Frau arbeiten geht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall in Ordnung.
So, Papa ist hungrig.
(Wenn man sich wie Lana und Martin
übers Internet kennenlernt,
kann man schon vor dem ersten Treffen
die Rahmenbedingungen abstecken
und Wünsche anbringen.)
(Deshalb haben sich die beiden
schon früh über Kinder unterhalten.)
Wo ist hier "ten"? Ich seh's nicht.
Sei hat ja bereits
einen älteren Sohn.
Als ich sie per Skype kennenlernte,
war mir das im Prinzip egal.
"Okay, wenn sie keine Kinder will,
dann eben nicht. Okay."
Und dann ...
... haben wir uns doch entschieden,
ein Kind zu bekommen.
Es war v.a. mein Wunsch
und sie fand dann:
"Gut, dann machen wir das noch mal."
Aber für sie war es natürlich
schon noch happig,
nachdem sie gedacht hatte:
"Mein ältester Sohn ist ausgeflogen,
mit Kindern habe ich
nichts mehr zu tun."
Für sie war es dann doch etwas
schwierig, in diesem Alter ...
Papa, schau!
- Cool.
... noch mal eine Schwangerschaft
einzugehen und ein Kind aufzuziehen.
Was machst du jetzt?
Leon, was ist das?
- "Blue".
Ja, aber was "blue"?
Ich hatte
viele Möglichkeiten zu heiraten,
aber das wäre nicht
aus Liebe gewesen.
Dann kam Martin - wow!
Ich hatte wegen meines Englisch
eigentlich damit gerechnet,
einen wesentlich älteren Engländer
zu heiraten
und dann so ein Püppchen zu werden.
Ich weiss nicht, was du hier machst.
Lana?
- Ja, ja, wir essen gleich.
Ich muss dann irgendwann
arbeiten gehen.
Was ist?
- Ich muss arbeiten.
Okay, vielleicht
kannst du schon mal anfangen.
Ja, eben.
- 5 Min.
Das ist für dich.
Das ist für uns.
(Es war alles geplant, aber dann
hat die Liebe dazwischengefunkt.)
(Und so ist Lana jetzt
Hausfrau im Bündnerland
anstatt einer englischen Lady.)
Bye bye. Kuss!
Okay.
Ja, ja.
- Ja, ja.
(Ihr Englisch
braucht sie aber nach wie vor,
denn sie habe noch nicht richtig
Zeit gefunden, Deutsch zu lernen.)
Bye bye.
Am Anfang war es natürlich so,
dass sie noch kein Deutsch sprach,
oder höchstens
ein paar Brocken Deutsch.
Ich sprach kein Russisch.
Also war das von Anfang an
unsere Sprache.
Leider, leider.
Wir probieren ... werden.
Es schränkt natürlich etwas ein,
weil wir beide
nicht perfekt Englisch sprechen.
Also haben wir
nicht die Möglichkeit,
irgendwelche philosophischen,
tiefgründigen Gespräche zu führen
in englischer Sprache -
das haben wir nicht.
Aber ich kann mich
auch nicht daran erinnern,
dass ich in früheren Beziehungen
sehr tiefgründig diskutiert hätte.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
(Immer wieder lädt Lana
ukrainische Freundinnen zu sich ein.)
(Sie geniessen es,
miteinander Russisch zu sprechen.)
(Ein wichtiges Stück Heimat
für Lana.)
In unserer russischen Muttersprache
können wir unsere Emotionen
viel besser und wortreicher
miteinander teilen.
Wir können hier
frei von der Seele plaudern
und unseren Gefühlen
freien Lauf lassen.
(In diesem Kreis können
die Freundinnen auch die Unterschiede
zwischen der schweizerischen und
ukrainischen Mentalität besprechen.)
(Katharinas Ehe z.B.
hat nicht standgehalten.)
(Sie hat sich von ihrem
Schweizer Ehemann scheiden lassen.)
Wir sind hitziger, aufbrausender,
direkter, aber auch viel offener.
Wir sagen, was wir denken.
Die Schweizer
halten sich in der Regel zurück.
Sie finden
dieses direkte Auftreten frech.
(Die sprichwörtliche
ukrainische Gastfreundschaft.)
(Lana verteilt allen
noch ein Geschenk.)
Spasibo, spasibo!
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Wie viel ist 7/8 von 1'000?
875.
Okay, was sind wir?
Und hier ist das Produkt.
Also!
(Seit 22 Jahren ist Martin
Oberstufenlehrer in Thusis.)
(Wegziehen
kam für ihn nicht infrage.)
(Schon gar nicht in die Ukraine.)
Meiner Ansicht nach
haben wir ein ganz tolles System
mit unserer Demokratie, mit
unserem Wirtschaftssystem und allem.
Und auch politisch
ist die Lage sicher.
Ich sehe keinen Grund,
woanders zu leben.
Und für sie
war es eigentlich auch klar.
Sie wollte eher weg aus der Ukraine.
You wanted to leave the Ukraine?
Live or leave?
Leave, go out.
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe meine Familie aufgegeben,
die dort geblieben ist.
Ich habe
meinen Lebensstil aufgegeben,
meine ...
... das ganze Sozialleben,
das ich dort hatte.
Freundinnen,
die ich seit 20, 30 Jahren habe.
Unsere Kinder
sind zusammen aufgewachsen.
Man gibt sein Leben auf,
den Lebensstil,
den man zu jenem Zeitpunkt lebt.
Ich war erstaunt
und fühlte mich sehr geliebt.
Ich fragte mich,
ob ich dasselbe getan hätte,
und ich bin nicht sicher,
ob ich das damals gekonnt hätte.
* Indianische Flötenklänge *
(Brigitte und Jay:
er Native American
vom Stamm der Nakota
und Brigitte jetzt seine Squaw.)
(Die Prärie von Montana
ist ein Ort magischer Schönheit.)
Smile big!
- Yeah, I am smiling.
I don't want to make Chinese eyes.
(So überwältigend,
dass sich die beiden
mit einem indianischen Dank
erkenntlich zeigen.)
(Das Ritual verlangt,
dass man etwas Tabak verstreut.)
* Kuss *
(So unendlich die Weite Montanas,
so bescheiden
ist Brigitte und Jays Zuhause.)
(Ein fix montierter Trailer
auf einem kleinen Stück Land.)
Okay. Thanks, dear.
(Brigitte hat zwei Töchter.)
(Diese sind in der Schweiz geblieben,
als Brigitte
alles hinter sich gelassen hat
und zu Jay in die USA gezogen ist.)
... damit es nicht zu trocken ist.
Heiratsanträge müssen doch
immer toll und pompös sein.
Aber meiner war einfach
so besonders,
wie unsere Ehe es ist.
Er hatte gerade geduscht,
er kam raus,
nur das Handtuch um sich,
und kniete mit nassen Haaren
vor mir nieder
und machte mir einen Heiratsantrag.
Ich fand das so mega cool.
Es war einfach so spontan.
Nicht ... nicht geplant
und ohne grosses Tamtam
oder was weiss ich was.
Es war einfach spontan.
Er wusste einfach:
"Ich will das machen."
Ja.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Aufregend.
Und v.a. auch
die eigentliche Zeremonie.
Ich dachte: "Oh, das habe ich
schon oft im Film gesehen."
Weil es auf Englisch war,
war es genau so wie in den Filmen.
Native Americans
sollten nicht weinen.
Aber ich habe geweint an diesem Tag.
Aus lauter Glück.
Ich gebe es ungern zu.
Aber es stimmt,
ich war so glücklich.
Deine Haare waren
noch ganz schön schwarz.
There was nothing on the walls.
No, I'm talking about
your black hair.
Oh. Oh, yeah.
But I love that grey hair in here.
It looks beautiful.
* Lachen, Kuss *
En Guete.
- Good morning.
Guten Appetit.
- Excellent, baby.
Ach ja, das fehlt noch!
Ein kleines, kleines bisschen -
gegen das Heimweh.
Okay, cool.
Ich mache immer ...
Wenn er zu Hause ist,
mache ich immer seine Haare.
Bei den Indianern
machen das die Frauen.
Und wenn man auf der Strasse
einen Indianer sieht,
der nur einen Pferdeschwanz hat,
dann ist er meistens Single.
Denn sonst würde ihm
seine Frau die Haare ...
... take care of his hair.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
# Take my hand.
Le mariage a simplement evolue ...
Die Hochzeit hat sich rasch
zu einem grösseren Event entwickelt.
Wir wollten zuerst
etwas Kleineres machen.
Er war das.
Du kanntest meine Familie nicht.
Okay, jetzt schon.
Ich sagte ...
Natürlich haben wir uns
wie verrückt geliebt.
Aber diese Hochzeit war v.a.
eine rechtliche Angelegenheit.
Ich fand:
"Wir halten den Ball noch flach,
und wenn wir wirklich denken, jetzt
ist eine richtige Hochzeit angesagt,
dann machen wir eine Fete."
Aber das läuft bei Bonvins nicht.
Es wurde dann etwas
auf die Beine gestellt.
Es war sensationell, aber
ich hätte etwas Einfacheres gemacht.
(Das erste Nachtessen in Quebec.)
(Davids ganze Familie
ist zusammengekommen,
um Thomas willkommen zu heissen.)
(Er versteht bei kanadischem
Französisch nur Bahnhof.)
Ich verstehe zwar nichts,
aber sie sind nett.
(Thomas) Oh ja.
Willkommen zu Hause, Schätzli.
Tres bien!
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Das Hin und Her ist schwierig.
Das sind dann
sehr intensive Momente.
Ganz viele Aktivitäten.
Dann muss man sich
wieder ziehen lassen.
Man weint,
ist zwei oder drei Monate allein.
Jetzt bin ich wieder glücklich,
dass das vorbei ist.
Das ist eine grosse Erleichterung.
Das befreit den Geist.
* Lachen, Gespräche *
Sie macht gern Pläne
und ich schaue, was passiert.
Die Dinge ändern sich,
man kann gar nicht planen.
Das ist
wie das neuseeländische Wetter,
das wechselt auch alle 5 Min.
Ich gehe es langsam an
und verstehe gar nicht,
warum sie immer so gestresst ist.
Es kommt immer alles gut,
und wenn nicht,
dann findet sich eine Lösung.
Ein Plan B.
Man kann nicht
zu viele Pläne machen im Leben.
Ein paar.
- Ein paar, ja.
* Blöken *
(Auckland,
die grösste Stadt Neuseelands.)
(Hier wohnt ein grosser Teil
von AJs Verwandtschaft.)
(Sie sind ein wichtiger Anker für AJ,
aber auch für Katja.)
Sie wohnen alle hier?
- Genau.
Sie haben es gekauft,
aber dann auch noch viel angebaut.
Dieses Glas ist Judes ganzer Stolz.
Das ist noch neu.
Ja.
Hello!
How are you?
- Good.
How was the fishing?
- It was good.
Wir haben sie geweckt.
Aber sie muss sowieso aufstehen.
Oh!
Geht es wieder zu?
Schauen wir, wo Grandma Juju ist.
Zieht sie sich an?
It is so hot.
- Just going for a swim.
I might too.
Hello, darling!
You were such a good girl.
- Was she?
We went swimming in the pond,
didn't we?
And washed the dollies.
(Grandma Jude
ist eigentlich AJs Tante
und so etwas wie die neuseeländische
Ersatzmutter für Katja.)
(Eine Frau mit viel Familiensinn,
einem grossen Herzen
und vier Schwiegertöchtern.)
Gross!
Grossartig. Sie ist wirklich
eine grossartige Frau.
Ich wüsste nicht,
was ich hier ohne sie machen würde.
Sie ist die Beste.
Sie ist wirklich
meine Mutter in Neuseeland.
Ja, sie ist Gold wert.
Auch meine Mutter ist froh,
dass ich hier noch eine Mutter habe.
Ja, Schätzchen?
Du willst schwimmen gehen?
Ziehen wir die Badehosen an?
* Liebliche Musik *
Girls,
I want to introduce you to Mona.
Nice to meet you. I'm Mona.
Mona is here from Switzerland.
This is my other beautiful
daughter-in-law, Gina.
Nice to meet you.
* Donnern *
Yeah, but people
are doing side angles.
And you're diving.
(AJ hatte eine schwierige Kindheit.)
(Nachdem seine Mutter
die Familie verlassen hatte,
wurde seine Grossmutter
zur wichtigsten Bezugsperson.)
(Sein Vater, ein Maori,
starb schon früh bei einem Unfall.)
(Jetzt hat AJ selbst ein Kind
und ist für Narja
ein präsenter und liebevoller Vater.)
Hast du dich verändert,
als du Vater geworden bist?
Ja, das geschieht wohl allen,
aber das ist eine gute Veränderung.
In what way?
Man hat
eine neue Sicht auf die Dinge,
man kann nicht nur
auf sich selber achten
und tun und lassen, was man will.
Da gibt es jemand anderen zu Hause.
Das ist gut.
My turn now!
- Okay.
Wait on, wait on!
Don't let her hit you.
That's as high
as you can go right now.
(Mit etwa 20 Jahren, als nach dem
Vater auch seine Grossmutter starb,
geriet AJs Leben
kurzfristig aus den Fugen.)
You need to share.
(Damals hat ihn Jude
in ihre grosse Familie geholt.)
This is basil from my garden.
Ich habe hart gearbeitet, um ihn
in unsere Familie zu integrieren.
Wir wollten ihn unbedingt
genau gleich behandeln
wie unsere anderen Kinder.
Was denkst du, werden AJ und Katja
zurück in die Schweiz gehen,
um dort zu leben?
Für immer?
I would love for that to happen,
but ...
Nein, das glaube ich leider nicht.
AJ kann Neuseeland nicht verlassen.
Das hat mit seiner Kindheit zu tun.
Ihm fehlt die Geborgenheit.
Das wird wohl sehr hart für Katja.
Eine grosse Herausforderung
für ihre Ehe.
Wenn man frisch verliebt ist,
denkt man,
man könne das Leben zu zweit
auf einer einsamen Insel verbringen,
aber mit den Jahren
zeigt sich eine andere Realität.
(Zuerst gibt es noch einen Maori-Dank
für das tägliche Essen.)
So, if you repeat after me,
sentence by sentence. It goes:
* Sie spricht maori,
die anderen sprechen ihr nach.*
(June)
Please, everyone help themselves.
Thank you.
* Sanfte Klänge, Gespräche *
Wenn man aus unterschiedlichen
Ländern kommt, muss man akzeptieren,
dass derjenige,
der in das fremde Land gezogen ist,
wahrscheinlich Heimweh hat
oder Schwierigkeiten damit hat.
Man muss ihm die Freiheit lassen,
immer wieder mal nach Hause
zu gehen - auch mal alleine.
In unserem Fall ist es
manchmal fast einfacher,
wenn ich ohne AJ nach Hause gehe
oder wenn er erst später nachkommt,
denn dann können wir in meiner
Familie einfach miteinander reden,
ohne dass ich mich schlecht fühle,
weil ich immer übersetzen
oder ihm irgendwelche Aktivitäten
bieten muss.
I will see you later.
Bye bye, love you!
Bye.
Take care, drive safely!
I'll text you
when we're on our way back.
Weisst du, wo wir hingehen?
Wir gehen nach Rotorua und fahren
mit den Schlitten den Berg runter.
* Handyklingeln *
Ich muss kurz rangehen.
Ist das okay? - Ja.
Hi, Matt.
Yeah, see you later.
- Bye.
Who's that?
- Das war Matt.
Das ist mein Assistent.
Bist du immer erreichbar fürs Büro?
Sogar am Mamatag?
Ja.
Eigentlich schon.
Sie rufen immer an.
(Das Naturwunder von Rotorua -
Schlammtümpel,
Geysire und heisse Quellen.)
(Und über allem liegt
der intensive Geruch von Schwefel.)
* Verspielte Klänge *
(Aber all das
interessiert Narja nicht.)
(Sie will mit ihrer Mutter rodeln.)
Woohoo!
* Fröhliche Musik *
Du hast ja im Winter Heuschnupfen.
Ja.
Auch das ist Neuseeland.
- Heuschnupfen im Dezember.
Jetzt so aus der Distanz betrachtet:
Eine Beziehung mit einem Mann von
der anderen Seite der Welt zu führen,
ist es einfacher oder schwieriger
geworden, als du dachtest?
Hm, gute Frage.
* Seufzen *
Das Schwierige,
auf jeden Fall für mich,
ist eigentlich nur, dass ich
meine Familie und Freunde vermisse.
Aber in unserer Beziehung ...
... gibt es
nicht viele Schwierigkeiten,
weil wir
aus verschiedenen Ländern stammen.
Es ist mehr die Distanz
zu meiner Familie und meiner Heimat.
Hättest du gedacht,
dass du solches Heimweh bekommst?
Nein, und am Anfang
hatte ich nie Heimweh.
Erst als ...
... mein Vater starb,
ganz plötzlich durch einen Unfall.
In solchen Situationen fährt es
richtig ein, wenn man weit weg ist.
Und dann ...
Eine schwierige Zeit für dich.
- Ja.
Dann überlegt man sich doch:
"Uff ..."
"Ist das wirklich ..."
Und wenn jemand Nahestehendes,
eben ein Elternteil stirbt
und man nur noch einen hat,
dann ist es
auch noch mal schwieriger.
Man entwickelt Schuldgefühle.
Hast du Schuldgefühle?
- Ja.
Deiner Mutter gegenüber?
Ja, ziemlich oft. Sorry.
Ja.
- Aber ...
Kommt das von dir selbst oder
vermittelt sie dir dieses Gefühl?
Nein, an ihr
liegt es überhaupt nicht.
Die macht man sich einfach -
oder ich.
Und jetzt mit ihr noch stärker,
denn man sieht, wie sehr sie sie mag
und wie wenig sie mitbekommt,
weil sie sie höchstens
ein bis zwei Monate am Stück sieht
und dann wieder ganz lange nicht.
Und schnell ist wieder ein Jahr rum.
Narja wächst so schnell
und vergisst auch schnell.
Das ist hart für sie. Und für mich.
Ich denke, jeder von uns ...
... hat jeweils - also nicht
für die Liebe, aber für den Umzug -
Freunde und Familie
zurücklassen müssen.
Ich glaube ...
Ich habe ihn ein paar Mal gefragt:
"Hast du kein Heimweh?"
Und er hat Nein gesagt.
Aber ich habe es gemerkt.
Aber ich glaube auch, man denkt:
"Ich bin
in einer glücklichen Beziehung."
"Ich bin in einem schönen Land."
"Im Studium läuft es,
ich müsste zufrieden sein."
Aber das ist nicht alles.
(Jetzt versuchen sie es umgekehrt.)
(Klappt das, wenn man mit 47 Jahren
ins Kinderzimmer
bei den Schwiegereltern einzieht?)
So.
- Un peu de lumiere.
Oui.
- On doit le bouger.
Okay.
Wäre es nicht so kalt, könnten wir
auch im Zelt wohnen. Das ist egal.
(Nächsten Freitag
lernen wir Nancy und Demis kennen,
die einen komplizierten Start
hatten.)
Sie erteilte mir
so eine extreme Abfuhr,
ich konnte das nicht
auf mir sitzen lassen.
(Und auch Lana und Martin
mussten eine Krise durchleben.)
Ich dachte wirklich,
dass sie sich scheiden lassen will.
(Hin und weg.)